[موسيقى]
نرحب بكل المشاهدين ورحب بضيوف البرنامج
الذين تشاهدونهم على الشاشه الذين يمكنكم
ان تتفاعلوا معهم على صفحتنا على فيسبوك
او على صفحه البرنامج على تويتر في النقاش
بعد شهرين ونصف من بدايه الاحتجاجات التي
جاءت اثر مقتل ماسا ميني ما الذي تغير
فيران تم الغاء شرطه الاخلاق طيب ما ستقيه
هذا القرار والى اي حد جاء لارضاء
المتظاهرين هل يعني هذا انا وضعيه المراه
في ايران ستتغير بموجب هذا القرار ثم
النداء الى الاضراب العام طيله ثلاث ايام
نداء جاء على مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي ما
هي حدود نجاح سعيد بان يناقش الموضوع معي
هنا في الاستديو مايا خضراء
في جامعه ايباد سعيد بان يكون معي من
بيروت محمد شمس وهو باحثه سياسي واستاد في
الجامعه اللبنانيه سعيد بان يكون معنا من
القاهره محمد محسن ابو النور رئيس المنتدى
العربي لتحليل السياسات الايرانيه اهلا
وسهلا بكم ابدا مع ضيفي من بيروت هل تعتقد
فعلا ان هذا القرار الذي اتخذ فيما يتعلق
بالغاء شرطه الاخلاق هو قرار يتمتع بصدقيه
تحياتي لك ولمشاهده القنوات والضيوفك
الكرام همم الموضوع همم شرطه الاخلاق في
ايران وايضا قانون الحجاب في هذا البلد
ليس جديدا النقاش فيه كان قبل عده سنوات
في حكومه الرئيس محمود احمد النجاد وقبله
في حكومه الرئيس الاصلاح السيد محمد خاتمي
الذي استعمل القبضه الحديديه في فرد
القانون وشرطه الاخلاق وايضا هذا الامر تم
مناقشته في حكومه السيد الشيخ روحاني
واليوم قبل انطلاق الاحداث الاخيره
الاحتجاجات واعمال الشغب في ايران السيد
رئيسي في المجلس الاعلى للثقافه للثوره
الثقافيه يعني قبل عده اشهر كان صوت هذه
معلومات كان صوت لالغاء او تجميد عمل شرطه
الاخلاق
وتمت اراء يعني سياسيه وفقيه في ايران منذ
عده سنوات
همم تتحدث عن فصل هذا الموضوع ان القضايا
الفقهيه تختلف عن القوانين قضيه حجاب
المراه هو هي قضيه دينيه ترتبط في علاقه
المراه مع ربها يعني بعلاقه بعلاقه دينيه
اما فيما يخص القانون هذا يعود الى
القانون القانون في ايران بعد انتصار
الثوره الاسلاميه صار في استفتاء على
الدستور دستور النظام الاسلامي و99% من
الايرانيين صوتوا على هذا الدستور وبناء
عليه كان المجلس الاعلى للثوره ثقافيه
اتخذ هذا القرار تحت عنوان همم قانون
الحجاب لهذا لهذا الامر قانوني ينبغي ان
نميز بين امرين القانوني والفقهيه في
الموضوع الفقهي هناك خلافات ونقاشات وفي
الموضوع القانوني ايضا يوم هناك نقاش في
مجلس الشورى الايراني وقال انه سيبد في
هذا الامر بعد شهرين اعتقد ان الموقف هو
مرونا من قبل النظام وان موقفا مسبقا من
قبل السيد رئيس قبل الاح اي ان ما حدث ليس
لم ياتي نتيجه استجابه المتظاهرين او
المحتاجين واعمال الشغب الاخيره
قبل ان تبدا الاحتجاجات
يعني اولا اريد التعليق على هذا الرقم
الذي تفضل به
من بيروت تم التصويت على القانون الاسلامي
بنسبه 99% يعني هذا الرقم ليس برقم
ديمقراطي ونحن نعلم الشعب الايراني يرزح
تحت اي ثقل نظام هذا النظام ديني لا يوجد
هناك الدستور هو الدستور ديني وهي جمهوريه
اسلاميه لذلك هذا التكتيك بالغاء شرطه
الاخلاق التي تم همم هذا همم هذه المجموعه
التي تم وضعها همم تحت ولايه محمود احمدي
نجاد هي لم تكن موجوده ولكن كان الحجاب
مفروضا تحت هذا النظام لذلك اليوم عندما
يختفي او تختفي هذه المجموعه او هذه
الشرطه هذا الامر لن يغير شيئا كثيرا
كبيرا في في ايران نرى حتى اليوم انه هناك
قتله انه هناك بطش ضد المتظاهرين واذا ما
تابعنا نوعا ما حركه
الظاهرين هناك وايضا الناشطين الايرانيين
الذين لديهم المقدره على التعبير عن رايهم
من بلدان كالبلايات المتحده او من بلدان
اوروبيه كماسيح علي نجاد المتواجده في في
الولايات المتحده هي تقول وهي خبيره هذا
النظام وهي نوعا ما هربت من هذا النظام
الديني في ايران تقول ان هذا التدبير هو
فقط تكتيك لذرع الرماد في العيون وان
الاحتجاجات همم ستبقى في ايران وان اذا ما
كانت هذه الشرطه هي التي ستلاحق النساء في
ايران هناك الحرس الثوري وهذا هذا امر
مترسخ جدا في هذا النظام لا هو بل هو
ركيزه هذا النظام لذلك تنتهي الشرطه ولكن
ها هو الحرس الثوري الذي ممكن ان يقبض على
اي محتاج همم ينتقد النظام ممكن ايضا ان
يتوسع خارج ايران وهو يصدر الثوره غنيه
منذ سنه 1979 لذلك هذا التدبير الصغير هو
ذر للرماد في العيون طيب محمد همم ضيفي من
القاهره هل ابدا هل تسمعني ضيفني من
القاهره
نعم اسمع بوضوح تفضل لا يمكن ان تتفاعل مع
الضيفين انت في الوسط يلا تفضل
في الواقع لم اسمع الاسئله او لم اسمع
الحوار
في الاتصالات
وانه سبق ايضا حتى ان طرحت هذه الفكره على
اساس على الاقل الغاء شرطه الاخلاق ولا
الاموريه دينيه وفقهيه بالاساس وهنا طبعا
ما قدر تقول هو نظام ديني هو النظام يعني
يفرض هو النظام يريد الاحتجاجات وهذا
التوقيت ليس بالتوقيت المناسب وهو مجرد
رامات في العيون
عظيم ااا طبعا انا برحب بحضرتك وبالخوه
الافاضل والزملاء من باريس ومن بيروت
ودعني اعبر عن يعني نقطه توضيحيه كي يعني
نضبط الامور اذا سمحت دي تاصيليا يعني
باختصار برنامج
[ضحك]
تقصيليا اه تاصيليا همم النظام الايراني
عودنا او عفوا الانظمه الايرانيه عودتنا
تاريخيا انها لا تستجيب ليه الحركات
السياسيه الا بضغوط هائله من الشارع او من
الخارج هذا في التاريخ الايراني يعني
الثمانيه عشر اسره نجي حكمت ايران منذ قبل
التاريخ حتى الان تفعل ذلك بكل بساطه
الامر الثاني وهو المهم جدا ان النظام
الايراني هو النظام برجماتي لديه قدره
هائله على البقاء على قيد الحياه السياسيه
وهو يعرف متى ي- يعني يزوج مثل هذه الامور
الى همم الواجهه ومتى يسحب مثل هذه الامور
الى وجهها والدليل ان كان هناك همم تنظيما
همم موازيا تقريبا الى شرطه الاخلاق اسمه
كوميتيه او كميتا وهذا التنظيم تم حله
ايضا في سنوات ماضيه بعد ضغوط هائله من
الشارع في التسعينيات وبالتالي الان عندما
تقول ايران انها حلت شرطه الاخلاق بمناسبه
همم المدعي العام الايراني لم يقل انه تم
شرطه الاخلاق بالقارئ انه تم تجميد هذه
الشرطه بمعنى ان هذا التجميد هو كان عباره
عن دوريات تعرب بانها دوريات للضمان
الاجتماعي
والاخلاقي هذا التجميد معناه ماذا ان كانت
هناك خمسه جهات توزع منسوبيها وافرادها في
الشوارع للقيام او لتطبيق مثل هذا القانون
هذه الجهات هي صوت القضائيه على الحارس
السوري الاستخبارات الداخليه في راسه همم
ثم الباسيج الى جان طبعا الامن الداخليه
هذه القوات كانت موجوده في الشارع وهي
مسلحه لديها قدره على الدكتيه القضائيه
لديها قدره على احتجاز الناس والنساء في
الاقسام لديها ايضا همم صلاحيه تتعلق
باستتابه النساء اللواتي اا لا يرتدين
الحجاب الاسلامي المناسب من وجهه نظر
الشخص الذي يطبق مثل هذا القانون لذلك
اعتقد ان النظام لم يفعل هذه الخطوه الا
بعد ضغوط هائله من الشارع منذ السادس عشر
من سبتمبر لكن هل
قد يتراجع النظام عن هذا الامر لا اعتقد
ذلك لان النظام قد يعود بمثل هذه الشرطه
بمسميات مختلفه وعن طريق جهات مختلفه وهذه
امور فيها تفصيلات عميقه جدا في الشؤون
الايرانيه اذا كان الوقت الوقت يعني موجود
سوف
هذا الامر نترك محمد شمس يتفاعل معك او مع
ميت تفضل تفضل يا زلمه الامور هي جاءت تحت
الضغط حسب الضيفين
في الواقع يعني بدايه في ايران دوله قانون
ومؤسسات يعني القانون هو الذي يتحدث عندما
يتحدث المدعي العام عن تجميد شرطه الاخلاق
وليس حلها كما ذكرنا وافق ضيف المصري على
ما قاله نعم لكن هذا الامر يطبق في ايران
وليس هناك منطق في الحديث عن ان الحارس
الثوري قد يقوم بهذه المهمه
لانني انا زرت ايران وكنت في ايران عملت
صحفي عده سنوات في ايران واعرف ان هذه
الدوله تطبق القانون همم لكن ينبغي ان
نميز بين امرين قانون الحجاب وشرطه
الاخلاق شرطه الاخلاق موجوده في اغلب
الدول العربيه والاسلاميه التي تتحدث عن
عن موضوع عن يعني انتهاك العرف الاخلاقي
في المجتمع وليس موضوع الحجاب موضوع
الحجاب امر في مصر موجوده شرطه الاخلاق
والاداب في اغلب الدول العربيه موجوده
شرطه الاداب همم لذلك هذا الامر
اما الانتقائيه في مصر
السعوديه في السعوديه تم التخلي عنها ايضا
هناك نقطه جوهريه في هذا الامر
الضعيف المصري عن ان الانظمه في ايران لا
تتحرك الى نتيجه الضغوط يعني اي من
الانظمه في العالم لا تتحرك او تتغير بدون
ضغوط من الشارع هل تغير النظام المصري
يعني بعد 40 سنه النظام المصري لم يتغير
الا باراده شعبيه وبتحرك شعبي بمظاهرات
فهذه الانتقائيه بالتحامل على ايران
وكانها الدوله الوحيده التي تستجيب لامر
الناس في في مصر استخدم السلاح والعنف
والقتل اليوم في ايران عندما تقول انني
مستعده لاداء مرونه وتجميد شرطه الاخلاق
لا يعجب هذا الامر
لكن احنا اردنا نفهم من كان ذلك تحت الضغط
بس نقطه بعد نقطه نقطه نظام
الذين يقارنوا شرطه الاخلاق في ايران باي
جهه داخليه اخرى في اي دوله عربيه بما
فيها مصر طبعا مصر فيها شرطه الاداب هذه
شرطه لا علاقه لها بما يحدث في الشارع
يعني لا يوجد فتاه تمشي في الشارع بغير
حجاب مثلا يستوقفها شخص يقول لها لماذا لا
تتجين الحجاب لكن المقارنه بين ايران
والدول العربيه الاخرى منها السعوديه مثلا
غير علميه لماذا اسمح لي اسمح لي انا اوضح
لك امر علمي بحث وانت استاذ اكاديمي همم
في ايران المجتمع اكثر ديبراليه عشرات
المرات من الدوله الدوله متشدده دينيه في
قراطيه لا خلاف على ذلك لكن المجتمع
الايراني مجتمع لابرالي هو انت تعرف ذلك
بحكم انك كنت هناك على العكس مثلا في
المملكه العربيه السعوديه
الدوله او الحكومه هي حكومه ليبراليه
المجتمع في منتهى بمناسبه انا زرت كل هذه
الدول واعرض ذلك جيدا فبالتالي لا تقارن
ما بين ايران والسعوديه لقيت الكره عند
بين ايران ومصر لماذا لان المجتمع والدوله
هنا في مصر على خط واحد وعاء وفي نسيج
واحد لذلك لا يوجد فرض شرطه مثلا يستوقف
فتاه يقول لها لماذا ترتدين مثل هذا
البنطال او مثل هذه الجنيلا وما الى ذلك
هذه مقاربه غير علميه وغير موجوده على ارض
الواقع بمناسبه نحن هنا عندنا نحلل الواقع
الايراني لا نهاجم النظام الايراني
بالمناسبه لان نحن لسنا طرف فيما يحدث هذا
صراع ما بين المجتمع والسلطه في ايران نحن
لسنتين في كل ما نفعله وهو اننا نحلل
الواقع الذي يجري نقطه ايضا جوهريه اذا
سمحت له
نقطه جمهوريه
يحدث في ايران
اشكرك جدا اشكرك جدا الذي يحدث في الشارع
الان ماذا هناك جهه موازيه لما تعرب بشرطه
الاخلاق اسمها اسمها هيئه الامر بالمعروف
والنهي عن المنكر هي ما تزال موجوده ولم
تحل ولم تجمد وهذه الجهه بالمناسبه هي
اصعب من شرطه الاخلاق لماذا شرطه الاخلاق
تابعه لما يعرف بالمجلس الاعلى للثوره
الثقافيه وهذا المجلس هو تابع لرئيس
الجمهوريه لكن اا هيئه الامر بالمعروف
والنهي عن المنكر هي تابعه لمنظمه الدعوه
الاسلاميه وهي منظمه تابعه لمجلس صيانه
الدستور وهذا المجلس تابع مباشره للمرشد
اذا عندما تريد ان تفك الارتباط ما بين
الشارع والذي يحدث من الحكومه يجب عليك ان
تخاطب المرشد لهذه المراه مباشره لتعديل
الدستور وليس له مجرد حل شرطه اخلاق في
الشارع
الزميل الزميل من مصر على كل هذه الفضيحات
وهذا ما كنتوا احاول قوله عندما تكلمت عن
الحارس السوري ولكن هذه مركزيه في النظام
الديني في
هذه نعم مركزيه ووجود المرشد الاعلى في
القوانين وفي الحياه السياسيه وفي الحياه
الاجتماعيه هو ما يعكر الامور في ايران
وارى اننا اليوم نتكلم عن تجميد شرطه
الاخلاق هو عمر نوعا ما يحرف الانظار عن
الكثير من المتغيرات الاخرى اليوم عندما
ارى ما يحدث في ايران هذا هذا القانون
بالنسبه له هو امر هامشي جدا ولا يغير به
مصر الامور ماذا يحدث فعليا في ايران حسب
همم هيئه الامم المتحده لحقوق الانسان انه
من راى نفسه هناك 400 قتيل من اول بدا هذه
المظاهرات من قام بقتلهم هذا اولا سنه
2018 كان هناك مظاهرات يحصى القتلى او سنه
2018 بالالاف وهناك تعتيم اعلام على كل
التعذيب حصل في السجون الايرانيه
وايضا كل هناك الكثير من المفقودين حتى
اليوم لا نعرف اي شيء عن مصيرهم لذلك
الدفاع عن تعليق كما يتقدم الزميل من
بيروت الذي احترم رايه بالطبع ولكن
الترحيب بهذا هو نوع ما كاننا ننسى ال 400
همم ضحيه كاننا ننسى ايضا ضحايا سنه 2018
وكاننا ننسى اذا ما اردنا ان نرى ابعد من
هذه هذا التكتيك جدا من قبل النظام
الايراني اليوم وهو تعليق شرطه الاخلاق
هذا يحرف الانذار عن كل انشطه ايران في
المنطقه يحرف الانذار عن فشل ايران في همم
التفاوض مع الغرب في الجي سي بي واي اليوم
القانون
الجيسي القانون النووي الايراني علق لماذا
لان النظام الايراني عركل ذلك
كما جوزيف بوريال بتقميد بعذرا بتقديم
مسوده لهذا القانون واتى الايرانيون بشروط
تعجيزيه ثلاثه شروط ليس لها صله ابدا بهذا
الاتفاق اليوم يريدون ان يفشلوا مع دول
الغرب ان يفشل ايضا في سياستهم في الشرق
الاوسط اليوم بان اصوات المعارضه بدات
ايضا تعلو ضد اذرع حزب الله في المنطقه
اين ذلك في العراق نرى ذلك في لبنان ايضا
والمعارضه التي تكون في وجه حزب الله لذلك
التدبير الصغير جدا بالنسبه لي وهو تعليق
شرطه الاخلاق هذا امر بالنسبه لي همم لا
يجب حتى التحدث عنه لانه لن يغير شيئا لا
للنساء في ايران ولا ولا ايضا للنساء في
الشرق الاوسط ولا في البلدان التي تعاني
من هذا النظام طيب نستمع لما قاله وزير
الخارج
ممكن يختلف مع دكتوره مايا بعد اذنك
اذا سمحت لي اختلف مع دكتوره مايا في في
نقطه الدكتوره مايا همم نوكيا نقطه جوهريه
النظام الايراني هذه المره وبالمناسبه هذا
النظام المجهود الان هم خبراء في كيفيه
اسقاط الانظمه لان كلهم شاركوا في اسقاط
نظام الشارع مضبوط فهذا النظام يعرف جيدا
ان ان التنازل همم والاعلان عن تجميد مثل
هذه الشرطه في هذا الوقت هو تنازل ضخم
ويعني اننا اذا كنا مثلا نقارن ما الذي
يحدث في الشارع الان ما بين الشعب او
المجتمع الدوله نقارن ذلك ما بين متنافسين
في ميزان للملاكمه اذا انا همم سددت لكمه
ورايت خصمي يتراجع ويسقط ويتاثر فانني سوف
اسدد اللكمه الثانيه والثالثه والرابعه
ولذلك اعتقد انه خطا استراتيجي ضخم ان همم
يعني يكون نظام الايراني وفقا له قناعاتك
بمثل هذا الامر الا لو انه بالفعل مجبر
على ذلك وهى خطوه ليست صغيره هي خطوه ضخمه
جدا لماذا لان النظام الايراني بنى حكمه
على ثلاثه ركائز في اوكراطيه اولا التحكم
في المجتمع عن طريق المراه وملابس الرجاله
وما لذلك اثنين وهو المهم اا الدعوه الى
ان امريكا واسرائيل هم الشيطان الاكبر
والاصغر الامر الثالث هو مواجهه الاستقبال
العالمي وحمايه المستضعفين في العالم هو
طبعا ما يعرف بالمد الشيعي هذه هي ركائز
الثقافيه الثلاثه هو النظام الايراني هذه
المره تخلى عن احدى هذه الركائز وهي خطوه
ضخمه لا يمكن ان يقلل منها لماذا لان
المجتمع سوف يتلقى هذا التنازل ويقوم
بتسديد ضربات اخرى الى صدر هذا النظام
لذلك اعتقد ان خامنئي قام بخطا استراتيجي
ضخم قد يكلفه الكثير من التنازلات في
الاشهر المقبله ان وصل المجتمع المظاهرات
في الشوارع في الاسابيع والاشهر المقبولين
نستمع الى ما قال وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه
ان بلانكن
هذا الامر مسروق لهم وليس لنا ما رايناه
منذ مقتل امينه هي الشجاعه وغير العاديه
للشباب الايراني وخاصه النساء اللواتي
قدنا الاحتجاجات ودافعنا عن الحق في قول
ما يريدنا قوله وارتداء ما يريدنا ارتدائه
اذا كان النظام قد استجاب الان بطريقه مال
تلك الاحتجاجات فيمكن ان يكون شيئا
ايجابيا لكن علينا ان نرى كيف سيكون في
الممارسه وما يفكر فيه الشعب الايراني
خطوه كبيره انت كيف تقرا كل هذه النداءات
الى اضراب عام لا يوجد له زعيم هذا النداء
وما مع ذلك هناك استجابه من قبل العديد من
المتاجر ومن قبل العديد من الجهاد في
ايران للدخول في هذا الاضراب لمده ثلاث
ايام
بدايه المجتمع الايراني ليس مجتمعا
ليبراليا مجتمع محافظ حتي في زمن الشاهل
التهلاوي عندما فرض قانون نزع الحجاب
بالقوه ذهبت الايرانيات الى ارتداء الحجاب
بكثره وبشكل لافت وملحوظ لمواجهه النظام
القمعي الشاهي شاهي يوم اذن فيما يخص
موضوع انطوني بلانكن يعني نذكر بانه قبل
اسابيع بايدا تحدث عن تحرير ايران
والمعلومات تؤكد ان هناك محاولات تسليح
للمعارضه الايرانيه ويعلن الامريكي عن ذلك
كان صرح في هذا الامر اكثر من مره بانه
يدعم المعارضه الكرديه المسلحه في مواجهه
النظام الايراني اما حديث الزميله في في
الاستديو لديكم عن 400 قطيفه هذا غير
دقيقه وزاره الداخليه الايرانيه تحدثت عن
رئتين وزاره
داخليه انا اتحداك اهو الايراني
كلمتين قتيل هم اغلبهم من الذين قتلوا
باعمال ارهابيه في تفجير المقام الديني في
شيراز وفي الاعتداء الارهابي في اصفهان من
قبل الجماعات الارهابيه اليوم ما يحدث في
ايران يعني ينبغي فقط لا يقدم مقاربه
دقيقه وشفافه للوضع هناك ثلاثه من
الاحتجاجات والمحتاجين في ايران شريحه
مجتماعيه شعبيه تطالب بالحريات وتحت
عناوين الفقر او الوضع الاقتصادي تتحرك
وهي وهذا العمل المشروع ومطلوب ايضا لكن
هناك شريحه اخرى سياسيه كالاحزاب
الانفصاليه الكرديه والاحزاب الارهابيه
كجمه العدل في سيستان وباجيستان وايضا
الكرديه الكردي الانفصالي المدعوم من
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه وعلى علاقه
وطيده مكان اسرائيل وبالتالي هناك مجموعات
مسلحه هناك ايضا الخطوه المشروع الثالث او
او الطرف الثالث هو ما يعرف بمشروع
العنكبوت الاسود هو مشروع اسرائيل امريكي
للانقضاض على جمهوريه الاسلاميه والنظام
في ايران وعبر عنه الامريكيون في اكثر من
مره وهذا متخصص في دعم الجماعات الارهابيه
والقيام باعمال عنف مسلح لهذا ما اقوله ان
اليوم المحتجين في ايران هم كبش محرقه
للمشروع الغربي بالانقضاض على ايران
ويدفعون ثمن ذلك ولذلك ضروري جدا ان
ينفصلوا عن الجماعات الارهابيه والتكفيريه
والانفصاليه همم هذا الامر يستغل لضاربه
المحتاجين همم هنا سؤال
نعم اما بموضوع الاضراب نعم هناك استجابه
من 10 الى 15 بالمئه اليوم وذلك يعني
طبيعه الحال كما ذكرت هناك محتاجين لديهم
ارائهم لديهم افكارهم اا وانا اعتقد ان
عدد المتظاهرين الذين خرجوا في مظاهرات
المعارضه الايرانيه خلال حوالي 70 يوم حتى
الان حوالي 100 الف متظاهر وهذا رقم كبير
نوعا ما لكن من الجهه المقابله تجد ان
المتظاهرين الموالين من النظام هم
بالملايين في يوم وقارعه الاستقبال
العالمي خارج 10 ملايين ايراني يرتدون
الحجاب ومع الحجاب والى جانب النظام في
جمهوريه الاسلاميه ضد التدخل الغربي يعني
عندنا بنقول الشعب الايراني ينبغي ان نكون
دقيقتين وشفافين ان هناك شريحه كبيره همم
واكثريه في النظام تدعم هذا النظام
الاسلامي وهناك شريحه معارضه لها الحق بان
تعارض وان تعبر عن رايها لكن ان تخرج
جماعه ارهابيه وتكفيريه ويستغلها الغرب
لضرب النظام هذا الذي يتحدث عنه وزير
الداخليه بان القتلى خرجوا
اغلبكم منها اولى او من الابرياء اليوم
نتحدث عن 47 دوله تتدخل في الشان الايراني
عن 2600 فضائيه موجهه ضد ايران 200 فضائيه
فقط ناطقه باللغه الفارسيه تدار من واشنطن
ومن بريطانيا في مواجهه لكي الوعي لدى
المواطن الايراني ومع ذلك نشاهد ان 10
ملايين يتظاهرون لصالح النظام الاسلامي في
ايران فهذا يدل على شعبيه هذا النظام وعلى
ان لديه قاعده قويه ومتينه رغم وجود
معارضه هي معارضه لها الحق في التظاهر
ولها الحق بالقيام باي عمل همم يعني مشروع
وقانوني محمد همم
يقول ان النظام له شعبيه رغم كل ما نسمع
يعني من نداءات الى الاضرابات والمظاهرات
والمستمر ماذا تجيب
بص توفيق انا طبعا بصراحه لا اريد ان ادخل
في سجال مع الاستاذ الدكتور
كل كل جمله قالها انا استطيع ان ابرهن على
عكسها تماما بالوثائق وبالادله ومع ذلك
ومع ذلك يعني لا اريد ان ادخل
على ذلك
حتى لا يبدو ك- وكاني ضد النظام الايراني
ولا مع النظام الايراني انا مع التحليل
ومع الواقع
الكلام
ضد النظام الايراني معلش
اذا اذا لم تريد ان ان لا لا انتم موضوعين
ولكن انا ساقول انا ضد هذا النظام اذا اذا
لم تريد القول انا ضد هذا النظام القاهره
النظام الايراني له ظهير شعبي نعم هل
الظهير الشعبي الذي يعمل مع النظام
الايراني هو قوي قوي جدا هل هذا الظهير هو
عقائدي نعم هل هذا الظهير هو يتحمل مع
النظام تابعات كبرى نعم هذا لا جدال فيه
الظهير الايراني
ههه
علميا وفقا وفقا للدراسات قبل مناسبه انا
حاصل على ماجستير واتنين دكتوراه في
الشؤون الايرانيه يعني انا لا افعل شيء في
حياتي الا شبين الايرانيه منذ ان ولدتني
امي للعلم يعني
الذي يحدث في ايران الذي يحدث في ايران
الذي يعمل مع النظام هو تقريبا ما بين
خمسه الى سبعه ملايين نسبه هذا لا جدال
فيه وهذا امر علمي المجتمع الايراني الان
تقريبا 85 مليون نسمه هل لك ان تتخيل ان
سبعه ملايين ناس ما في احد اكثر تقف مع
هذا النظام ضد 84 او ما يعدل طرح المجموع
يعني من 84 مليون نسمه انا اتحدى النظام
الايراني كمحلل في الشؤون الايرانيه ان
يدعو غدا الى استفتاء على الدستور لو
خمينا الى لديه الحد الادنى من الشجاعه
يفعل ذلك لكن طبعا لكنه لم يفعل ذلك الامر
الثاني هو ان يدعو هذا النظام كل الاقل
كليات التركمان والبلوش والعرب والقرد كل
الاقليات ان يدعوها الى همم استفتاء على
الانفصال لو حدث ذلك سوف يعني ايران سوف
تكون عباره عن خمسه محافظات فهران واصفهان
وكرمان
وفارس ومازن دراما فقط والباقي سوف ينقسم
وسوف يذهب دول اخرى اا هي لا تريد ان تعمل
مع هذا النظام الذي يعمل بمركزيه غير
موجوده في اي دوله في الشرق الاوسط لاسيما
وانه يفرض ثقافته الفارسيه ولغته الفارسيه
على كل الاعراق وكل الاطياف الاخرى حتى
انه لا يوجد مسجد سني واحد في طهران
وبالمناسبه من سوء حظ النظام ان ماسا مين
هي كرديه سنيه لو كانت شخصيه فارسيه من
شيراز او من اصفهان او ما الى ذلك لتغير
الوضع تماما هذه الاقليه السنيه الكبيره
التي يوجد لها خمسه احزاب على الحدود وهي
مسلحه واين نعم مدعومه من الغرب وتواجه
هذا النظام عسكريا من سوق حد هذا النظام
ان مهس هذه كانت فاكتا كرديه ولم تكن مثلا
فتاه عربيه او من اي فصيل اخر لذلك اعتقد
ان هذا الفصيل الذي يعمل مع النظام
الايراني هو فصيل قوي وعقائدي ويريد ان
يموت من باب حمايه المرشد لان هذا المرشد
هو بالنسبه لهؤلاء العقائديون هو غير الله
في وليس مجرد حاكم همم في همم الدوله
والدليل على ذلك ان الدستور كل ديباجه
الدستور تقضي بانه هناك بعض البنود لا
يمكن تغييرها مثل ان هذه الدوله هي دوله
اسلاميه تعمل بالمذهب الشيعي الجعفري
الاثني عشري مثل ان هذا مقام المشد لا
يمكن تغيير هذا المقام وفقا ل- المواد 110
من الدستور كل هذه المواد الدستوريه هي
مواد تجعل من ان المجتمع غير قادر على
احداث اي تغيير جوهري في ظل وجود مثل هذه
الصلاحيات الكثرويه التي لم يملكها حتى كل
الكثيره في عصر ما قبل الفتح الاسلامي
لذلك اعتقد اننا اعتقد فعلا مع انه وجود
هناك ظاهره قوي لان المجتمع ليه النظام
الايراني لكن المجتمع الان بدا يواجه هذا
الظهير وبدا يخرج وهو بمناسبه نقطه في
منتهى الاهميه توفيق عندما تنزل الشارع
وانت تعرف انك محمي من الدوله
غير انك تنزل وانت تعرف انك سوف تموت هذه
نكته جوهريه بالمناسبه اتمنى ان نحلل
الشؤون الايرانيه
يعني وصلت الضوء على هذه هذا التخصص للراي
العام العربي بدون تحيز للنظام او ضد هذا
النظام حتى نعرف النظام الايراني جيدا
ونعرف المجتمع الايراني جيدا اتمنى من
الدكتور محمد ان ينزل غدا الى شارع باليه
قصر مثلا ويرى تاكسي بني ضامن على سبيل
المثال قريش تقوده المراه يرعى عمليات
التجميل للمراه بالمناسبه 90% من النساء
الايرانيات اجرين عمليات تجميل في الانف
قصات شعر وصبغات شعر النساء الايرانيات في
الشوارع هي قصات شعر وصبغات اوروبيه ثاني
هذا المجتمع هذا المجتمع مجتمع في منتهى
الليبراليه هو مجتمع يعمل به مبدا
النيربوريز لا علاقه له بتاتا الركائز
الثقافيه التي يقوم عليها هذا النظام وانا
ارفض تماما الرفض ان اوصف من القاهره
بانني ضد هذا النظام او مع هذا النظام
شكرا جزيلا طيب اذا نحن امام يعني ليس
اشكال واحد العديد من الاشكاليه
ولكن دور المراه في كل ما يجري هل مثلا
هذه القرارات التي تقدم يمكن ان تكون في
صالح المراه
يعني لصالح المراه طالما طالما هناك فرض
للحجاب على الكثير من النساء هناك وحجاب
شرعي نعلم هو النقاب نوعا ما لهذه النساء
في ايران بالنسبه لي لا يوجد حريه لا يوجد
حريه لان على المراه اختيار اذا كانت تريد
ارتداء الحجاب او المظاهرات هل ستكون في
صالح المراه بالنسبه لي انا التي اخذت بعض
من جولات ثوره بيروت التي بالنسبه لي ايضا
فشلت ولكن المراه كانت في الطليعه والمراه
هي دائما التي تحمل لواء الثوره في اغلب
همم البلدان كان لي الثوره الفرنسيه
رموزها النسائيه اليوم في ايران نظام كبير
جدا يرتكز على حرس ثوري على ازرع في منطقه
الشرق الاوسط على برنامج نووي على مسيرات
على كل هذا امراه مهسا امين هي التي زلزلت
نوعا ما قعده اليوم هل
المتغيرات الجديده ستكون لصالح المراه او
هل المراه بالنسبه لي المراه الايرانيه
اليوم فهمت ان لديها دور للعبه في ما يجري
هناك وهناك الكثير من التحركات النسائيه
التي تحدث الكثير من التحركات النقابيه
التي المراه هي رائده في والجامعيه ايضا
لان المجتمع الايراني هو من اكثر
المجتمعات همم ثقافه في في المنطقه او هو
مثل المجتمع اللبناني المجتمع المصري هناك
الجامعات كبيره في ال- اا المجتمع
الايراني والنساء موجوده بشكل وثيق في هذه
الاوصاف ايضا لذلك بالنسبه لي هناك همم
امران اليوم هل المراه الايرانيه ستذهب
للاخر وستقود المجتمع نحو ليس فقط همم
ابطال او تعليق شرطه الاخلاق ولكن حتى
موسى قالت النظام الموجود هذا اولا لان
الشعب الايراني يرزح فقط تحت هول شرطه
شرطه الاخلاق ولكن تحتها هاول التضخم ايضا
الذي اتى بعد العقوبات الامريكيه بالفعل
الولايات المتحده انسحبت هي بشكل دونالد
ترامب لم يستشيل هم يستشر نعم بشكل اداء
احادي لم يستشر الايرانيين بذلك ولكن هناك
عقوبات تنزل ليس فقط بما خص الملف النووي
ولكن بمقاص حقوق الانسان هناك الكثير من
العقوبات في البرلمان الاوروبي وادعوا
الجميع للاطلاع عليها وهناك عقبات جديده
فرضت على ايران بما خاص حقوق المراه عذرا
وحقوق الانسان بشكل عام اليوم السؤال ليس
فقط المراه ليس فقط شرطه الاخلاق اليوم
يجب مسائله هذا النظام منذ اكثر من 40 عام
ماذا فعل هذا النظام في ايران ماذا فعل في
منطقه الشرق الاوسط وعلى هذا الشيء يتم
بناء نظره موضوعيه عن ما سيكون مستقبل هذا
النظام هل هذا النظام لديه الحق المودي مع
كل هذه الضحايا التي تقع مع كل هذه
الاحتجاجات مع علو اصوات المعارضين
الايرانيين من الدول الاوروبيه ودول الغرب
ايضا او هذا النظام اليوم سيضعف شيئا
فشيئا هذا هو السؤال
هل نفهم من خلال هذه المظاهرات ان هذه
التنازلات التي تم تقديمها بمثابه قبول
بمراجعات نوعا ما لطريقه تسير البلد خاصه
نجيلا جديدا ربما له الطموح اكبر من الجيل
الذي سابقه
دعني فقط اشير نقطتين او ثلاث نقط نقاط
قبل ان يجيب مباشره على سؤالك استاذ توفيق
انا رغم انني اختلف مع كل ما ذكرته وظيفتك
العزيزه في الاستديو لكن اتفق معها في امر
واحد ان المراه في ايران لديها دور ودور
اساسي وكبير همم يوم 52% من النساء
الايرانيات هم في الهيئه العلميه الهيئه
العلميه في الجامعات انا كنت ادرس في
جامعه طهران لمده خمس سنوات ايضا همم
وهناك 52% من الهيئات العلميه وايضا من
الطلاب الجامعات واكثر القاده الجماهيريين
اليوم في الحركه الشعبيه هم من النساء
اليوم والناشطين والمؤثرين وهذا يدل على
ان يعني حريه المراه في ايران هامش الحريه
كبير جدا انا برايي لا يمكن مقارنته
بالحريه الموجوده للمراه في اي دوله عربيه
عادى عن السعوديه السعوديه مش هنناقش
الموضوع بالسعوديه حقوق المراه غير موجوده
اساسا لكن الدول العربيه لا يوجد هامش
حريه للمراه كما هو موجود في ايران اما في
مغالطات الاستاذ من مصر مع ان محمد لو
سمحت تحدث عن الدكتور محمد
سؤال لو سمحت بعد اذنك كان وزيره في
الحكومه الايرانيه الان كم وزيره في
الحكومه الايرانيه الان
سؤال اخر كم وزيره في الحكومه المصريه
الرئيس الرئيس الايراني
لاخر الرئيس الايراني لديه عدد من
المستشفرات هناك العشرات من المدراء
العامين في حكومه رئيس حاليا لا يوجد
وتاريخ لكن نتحدث عن المراه في حياه
السياسيه موجوده كنائب للرئيس لو سمحت
ما المشكله
في الحكومه المصريه الان هل تعرف هذه
المعلومه
هل يعني ان النظام
الديمقراطي
طبعا
ليس بالضروره
يا جماعه
نعم نعم
انا اذكرك بالاخره والله
السنه في طهران
لا يوجد الطاقه
يعني هذا حلم الامريكي ان تتقسم ايران انا
احيلك الى تصريح لوزير الاستخبارات
الايراني في زمن الشاه هميون شهريار منذ
فتره وقال فيه بان انا غيرت رايي وقعدت
عملت مراجعه بطريقه محاربه النظام في لان
الغربي او الامريكي يريد تقسيم ايران الى
عده محافظات هذا ما يريده الامريكي ان
تنفصل كردستان
وباجيستان وان تنفصل خوزستان لكنه سقط هذا
المشروع ولم ينجح يعني بالامس الرئيسي زار
سلندج المدينه الكرديه السنيه وكانت صلاه
الجماعه بوجود علماء السنه وعلماء الشيعه
هلا تاخذين على مواضيع دول عربيه من ناقص
اي دوله عربيه حاليا حاليا مواضيع الدول
الاخرى قد ما بدك بنحكي بالموضوع
فاعتقد ان يعني الموضوع اليوم
الموضوع اليوم ان ايران لديها اعداء كثر
ولديه خصوم العقوبات الدوليه عليها لا
تعني انها غير محقه يعني ان ايران هي
ظالمه مثلا يعني لا تعني انه امريكا فرطت
عقوبات على ايران ان ايران مخطئه بل
امريكا هي المخطئه لانها تجوع شعبها
واليوم المظاهرات التي تخرج في الشارع على
خلفيات اقتصاديه هي نتيجه العقوبات
الامريكيه التي تدعو لها زميلتنا في
الاستديو لديه تدعو الى معاقبه ايران على
على سلوكها هذا وامر من 40 سنه لم لم اقل
يجب معاقبتها لم لم ادلبي كنت انه هناك
عقوبات
بمخس اا ملف حقوق الانسان وهذا امر غير
مرتبط بالبرنامج النووي هناك عقوبات كثيره
ضد ايران وليس فقط بما خص البرنامج النووي
هذا فقط ما كنت اريد قوله واوضعه
تصحيح
المعلوماتها النووي
السلمي».
كان وزير الخارجيه في عهد الشيخ ارده شيء
زاكي وطبعا هو له علاقه مطهره بالمصريين
لانه ممكن
عن تصريحه ميونخ
يعني
طيب طيب طيب
الايراني
لا يريد منه ان يكون في منتهى الانفتاح
مثل الحكومات الغربيه لان هذا لا ينصب
الثقافات في الشرق الاوسط وليس المطلوبه
منه ان يكون في منتهى الانغلاق بهذا الامر
بهذا الحجم والشكل على المجتمع يريد ان
يكون وسطه في العلاقه ما بين الحكومه
والمجتمع يترك الناس ان يفعله ما يشاؤون
وفقا لقوانين الناس هم الذين يختارونها
بالمناسبه هل تعرف ان ان طبعا هذه معلومه
اي احد يعرفها فيه شؤون الايرانيه كل
المرشحين الذين يخوضون الانتخابات من اول
رئيس الجمهوريه الى مجلس صيانه مجلس خبراء
القياده الى البرلمان الى حتى المجالس
المحليه الكرويه اا يتم تنقيه هؤلاء
المرشحون وبالتالي همم لا يعبرون البته عن
همم الذي يريده المجتمع في الداخل لذلك
النظام الايراني وهو نظام برجماتي في
منتهى الذكاء والدهاء ان اراد البقاء على
قيد الحياه السياسيه لسنوات اخرى عليه ان
همم
يشرك المجتمع نوعا ماء في القوانين
الجديده ويعدل فلسفه همم النظام الفلسفه
القائمه على التحكم في هذه همم في المراه
في المجتمع في ملابس الرجال في رابطه
العنق للرجال هذا الامر غير وارد لكن
الحقا وحتى اكون منصفا هناك نقطه في منتهى
الاهميه وانا وجهها للدكتوره مايا في
الاستوديو
باختصار باختصار برنامج
باختصار شديد في بعض المدن المقدسه التي
يوجد فيها حوزات مثل كم مثلا مثل مشهد مثل
هذه المدن
المجتمع الايراني المحافظ جدا في هذه
المدن فقط لا يقبل ان يخرج مثلا ايه الله
من الحوزه ويرى امراه سافره صفورا شديدا
هذا غير وارد في الاعراف الايرانيه
بالمناسبه الشادور الموجود الان هو ليس
رداء اسلاميه هو رداء من الاسر الثانيه
طبعا تم تصويره الى همم الشادور الشدور
الذي نراه الان ذلك مطلوب من الحكومه
الايرانيه الان هو النظام الايراني ان
يكون وسطا ما بين الليبراليه الشديده جدا
غير التحفظ شديد جدا حتى على همم بقائه
على كل حال الامور الوسط الشكر في
الختاميه خضراء همم بينو ده بيل شنو الشكر
ايضا همم وهي صحفيه استاذ في جماعه فهذا
الشكر من بيروت محمد شمس وهو باحث سياسي
استاذ في الجامعه اللبنانيه وشكرا من
القاهره لمحمد محسن ابو النور رئيس
المنتدى العربي لتحليل السياسات الايرانيه
شكرا لفريق البرنامج همس يا مريحه للجميع
[موسيقى]